Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Buenas.
Bueno, voy a arrancar con mi presentación.
Y esto es una charla
de una historia de amor,
una historia de amor
con las ideas de la libertad.
Y tiene tres capítulos
porque en la medida en que uno
va estudiando y va profundizando en esto
el romance va surgiendo
de distintas maneras.
Lo primero que me enamoró
del capitalismo y la libertad
básicamente fue que es una máquina
de sacar gente de la pobreza,
que es la máquina de la prosperidad,
que es la máquina del bienestar.
Pero, claro, cuando uno avanza en
esta idea se encuentra con detractores,
detractores que acusan
al sistema de ser injusto.
Entonces, el segundo momento del romance
arranca cuando uno empieza a estudiar
básicamente si el sistema es justo o no.
Y uno lo que descubre es,
no solo que es justo,
sino que además es el único
sistema que es justo.
Y, como si fuera poco,
la tercera etapa es una etapa estética,
donde claramente uno logra percibir
la superioridad estética del capitalismo.
Lo primero que hay que comprender
es que la historia de la humanidad
es una historia donde básicamente siempre
la condición del hombre fue la pobreza.
Es decir, hace poco más de 200 años
el 95 % de la población del planeta Tierra
estaba por debajo de
la línea de pobreza extrema,
es decir, vivían con menos
de un dolar diario.
Luego llegó el capitalismo.
Y ahora, digamos, en un mundo
que tiene siete veces más de personas
--porque hemos superado
los 7250 millones de habitantes--
hoy las personas debajo de
la línea extrema es menos del 5 %.
La contracara de esto es un aumento
fenomenal de la productividad.
Si uno toma la historia desde
el año cero hasta el año 2000,
el PBI per capita
se multiplicó por 12,9 veces.
Sin embargo, en los años que van entre
el cero y el 1800 solamente subió 40 %,
todo concentrado justo después
del descubrimiento de América.
Hasta que llegó el capitalismo
que generó la Revolución Industrial
y, a partir de ahí, el PBI
se multiplicó por más de nueve veces.
Lo otro que se percibe es una fuerte
aceleración del crecimiento en el mundo.
Fijensé que entre el cero y el 1800
el mundo crecía a una tasa
del 0,02 % en términos per capita.
Durante el siglo XIX, se acelera
casi 33 veces al saltar a 0,65;
en los primeros 50 años
del siglo XX, se creció al 1,06;
en la segunda parte, al 2,1;
y hoy el mundo crece al 3 %.
¿Qué significa esto?
Una explosión de crecimiento,
una aceleración fenomenal de crecimiento.
Es más, si Uds. consideran
que las cuentas nacionales
subestiman prácticamente
1,15 el crecimiento,
hoy el mundo estaría creciendo
cerca de 4,15 % per capita.
Eso significa que a lo largo de 100 años
vamos a estar multiplicando
el PBI per capita por 60 veces.
Es decir que en un siglo vamos
a estar logrando 4,6 veces más
de lo que logramos en toda
la historia de la humanidad.
¿Y eso se manifiesta en qué?
En el ritmo al cual
se duplica el PBI per capita:
originalmente se tardaba 3466 años.
Después, en el siglo XIX
ese número cayó a casi 107.
Después, a 65,74 en
la primera parte del siglo XX.
En la segunda, 33,35. Y ahora, 23,45.
Entonces, ¿dónde está la lógica de esto?
¿Qué es lo que sostiene toda esta magia?
La libertad, es el modelo de la libertad.
Es decir, aquellos países que son
más libres crecen más que el doble
de aquellos que son reprimidos.
¿Y cuál es la consecuencia?
Que aquellos que son más libres
tienen un PBI per capita
casi ocho veces más grande que el PBI
per capita de los países reprimidos.
No solo eso, sino que, además,
el decil más bajo de la distribución
--los que peor están--,
ganan 11 veces más de lo
que ganan los países reprimidos.
Es más, si Uds. se fijan, los del decil
más bajo, es decir, los más pobres,
en los países libres
tienen el doble de ingreso
que el ciudadano promedio
del país reprimido.
Pero como la distribución del ingreso
lleva un formato de un chi cuadrado,
una log normal,
eso significa que el 75 %
de la población, aproximadamente,
vive menos que con el ingreso promedio;
con lo cual acá quedaría bien claro
que es mucho mejor ser cola de león
que cabeza de ratón.
Es mejor ser el último orejón
del tarro en un país libre
que ser un jerarca en un país reprimido.
Es más, no solo eso, sino que, además,
en los países que son libres
la pobreza es 25 veces menor.
Y no solo eso, sino que,
además, la gente vive más.
Entonces, ¿de qué se sostiene
toda esta lógica virtuosa?
Son cinco instituciones,
las cinco instituciones del capitalismo.
Y estas van combinadas,
por ejemplo, la propiedad
privada con los mercados libres.
Es decir, Uds. no pueden
hacer transacciones voluntarias
si no son dueños de los bienes
que están transando.
Y, como consecuencia, es muy importante
que no haya intervención del Estado
porque --supongan Uds.--
podrían ser dueños nominalmente de algo,
pero el Estado les dice cómo usarlo,
cómo disponer de ello, a qué precio,
eso ya dejaría de ser libre,
por lo tanto, no es precio,
no estarían cumpliendo la función
que tendrían que cumplir
porque no tendrían sentido.
Entonces, es muy importante
la propiedad privada
para que sean Uds. los que
intercambian lo que está en juego.
Y que lo hagan libremente,
porque eso va a registrar un precio
y eso va a ser una señal
que se va a transmitir al sistema,
y el resto de los agentes de la economía
se van a coordinar respecto a ese precio;
y ahí viene la tercera institución
del capitalismo que es la competencia.
Es decir, que haya libre entrada y salida
para que los recursos se puedan reasignar
entre aquellos sectores donde el precio
señala que ahí hay escasez
y que hay problemas por resolver.
Y, como si todo esto fuera poco,
aparecen dos instituciones más:
una es la que tiene que ver
con la división del trabajo.
Lejos de esa falacia del hombre de paja
que acusa que el capitalismo
nos quiere a todos iguales... No.
Gracias a Dios somos todos distintos,
somos todos desiguales.
Y eso permite que cada uno
nos especialicemos
en aquello que somos
relativamente mejores.
Algo que se conoce como
"la ley de asociación" de Ricardo.
Eso permite que cada uno
de nosotros nos especialicemos
y nos veamos obligados a lo que es
la quinta institución del capitalismo
que es la cooperación social.
Uds. no pueden ser
exitosos en el capitalismo
sin servir al prójimo con bienes
de calidad a un mejor precio.
Uds. podrían odiar al otro,
sin embargo, como su progreso
económico y su bienestar material
dependen sustancialmente de
que su producto sea elegido por el otro,
lo tienen que tratar bien aunque lo odien.
Es decir, como decía Bastiat: "Donde
entra el comercio, no entran las balas".
Por eso no tiene sentido
esa estupidez de "la teoría del derrame".
No hay derrame. Desafío al que quiera...
¿Dónde la literatura liberal
habla del derrame?
Jamás hablamos de esto, porque
a Steve Jobs no se le derramaba nada,
a Bill Gates no se le derramaba nada;
ni ellos tampoco fueron un derrame de IBM.
Al que gana plata no se le derrama nada.
Acá se basa todo en cooperación social.
Y Uds. solamente pueden triunfar
satisfaciendo las
preferencias del prójimo.
Pero me vienen después con 'los nórdicos'.
"Porque el socialismo de los nórdicos..."
Vamos a ver qué hay de los nórdicos.
Por ejemplo, miren estos muchachos:
posición en "doing business".
Miren lo bien que están
los nórdicos en "doing business".
los nórdicos en libertad económica.
Miren dónde están los nórdicos
en materia de mercado laboral desregulado.
Y miren dónde están los nórdicos
en respeto a los derechos de propiedad.
Es decir, de socialismo creo que
les quedaron solamente los altos impuestos
los cuales, además, los empezaron
a bajar sustancialmente
después de que quebaron a fines de los 80.
Es decir que de socialismo
solo tienen el nombre,
porque en realidad son más promercado
de lo que la gente se cree.
Entonces, una vez que uno tiene
esta contundente evidencia empírica,
aparece el problema de 'la desigualdad'.
"No, porque el capitalismo es desigual".
Veamos en qué se sostiene
toda esa patraña mentirosa.
Primero, el problema de los socialistas
es que parten de una teoría del valor
que es una teoría estúpida,
llamada "teoría del valor-trabajo".
Es como que Uds., para
determinar el precio de algo,
pueden sumar los costos.
Es como que uno quisiera
producir vino en una sociedad,
entonces toma el costo
de la uva, el costo de la botella,
el costo de la etiqueta, el costo
del corcho, le pone un margen...
Y con eso vende.
¿A Uds. se les ocurre que puedo hacer
con una botella de vino, de ese gran vino,
en una sociedad de abstemios?
Me imagino que estará aumentando
la producción de vaselina
en este mismo momento.
Además, sería un mundo tan tonto,
que no habría quiebras.
Y yo creo que hay quiebras.
Es más, la "teoría de la explotación"
que sale de eso es una estupidez
porque, fijensé esto:
si hay algo que caracteriza al progreso
tecnológico impulsado por los empresarios
es que ahorra trabajo.
¿Cómo? ¿Está explotando los trabajadores
y utiliza tecnologías que ahorran trabajo
para reducir la explotación?
Ahora nos encontramos
con que la teoría de la explotación,
entonces, en el fondo, los empresarios
son benefactores sociales.
Me parece que los enganché
en alguna contradicción.
Por eso la teoría económica avanzó
hacia la "teoría subjetiva del valor",
donde los precios se determinan
por las preferencias y la escasez.
Y, a partir de ahí, surge
la remuneración de los factores.
La remuneración de los factores
viene dada por algo que se llama
el valor del producto marginal.
En el caso del trabajador sería el valor
del producto marginal del trabajo,
es decir, el salario, que
se compone de dos elementos:
el precio, donde intervienen
las preferencias y la escasez
con lo cual a Uds. no les puede ir bien
sin servir al prójimo con
bienes de calidad a un mejor precio
porque si no hay
quiebras y el precio es cero.
Por otro lado, tiene que ver
también con la productividad.
Si Uds. generan algo que sirve al mercado,
que sirve a la gente, les arregla la vida,
y además son productivos
¡se van a llenar de plata!
Pero está bien que así sea
porque van a ser benefactores sociales.
Entonces, eso permite ver
de qué va la distribución del ingreso.
En el fondo, la distribución del ingreso
tiene que ver con cómo Uds.
lograron servir al prójimo,
cuál eficiente fueron arreglándole
el problema a la sociedad.
Y cuanto más productivos
sean en ello, mejor les va a ir.
Entonces, pero ¿qué hay acerca
de la justifica del capitalismo?
¿Saben qué? Que todos
los intercambios son voluntarios.
Algo que los que miran teoría
del valor-trabajo no pueden entender
porque las cosas valen
según el trabajo que tienen.
Entonces, ¿qué van a intercambiar? Nada.
Yo les voy a contar
el caso de una sociedad
en la que aparece un chiquito que juega
al fútbol y la rompe, se llama Messi.
Claro, todos quieren tener a Messi,
porque saben que si tienen
a Messi van a ganar todo.
Ahora, ¿cuál es el punto?
El punto es que Messi, cuando todos
lo empiezan a demandar, ¿qué dice?
"Yo quiero más plata.
A punto tal que me gustaría llevarme
por mes dos recaudaciones del estadio",
con lo cual habría que estar
duplicando el precio de las entradas.
Los únicos que quieren
pagar eso son los catalanes.
Con lo cual lo contrata el Barcelona;
le pega un peludo a todos,
o sea, termina siendo
campeón por escándalo,
se le matan de risa los madrileños
en el propio Madrid; es todo una fiesta.
Ahora, cuando miran la distribución
del ingreso queda arriba Messi,
después los dirigentes del Barcelona
y los jugadores del Barcelona,
después todos los españoles
--salvo los catalanes--
y por último los catalanes.
¿Alguien podría decir que eso es injusto?
Si todos consiguieron lo que querían.
Pero vamos a otra sociedad:
supongan que yo subo
a un autobús con mi amiga Cristina,
que tiene fuertes valores sociales,
y se sienta a mi izquierda.
Entra de repente un señor
con los bolsillos repletos de dinero.
Eso a ella le parece
tremendamente violento e injusto.
Entonces, saca un bate de béisbol,
se lo pone en la cabeza y dice:
"O me das tu dinero,
o te rompo la cabeza".
Entonces, el hombre accede
gentilmente a darle el dinero.
Y, suponiendo que no se lo gaste ni
en carteras, ni en zapatos, ni en hoteles
y cosas por el estilo
la reparte igualitariamente
entre los que estaban en el autobús.
La pregunta es ¿Uds. podrían
decir que esa sociedad es más justa?
Entonces, lo que hay que ver también
es que, a lo largo del tiempo,
la distribución del ingreso va mejorando.
Miren lo que era en los 60.
En los 80 fue mucho menos desigual,
en los 2000 mucho menos desigual.
El índice de Gini se viene
cayendo estrepitosamente.
Y miren lo que era la distribución
del ingreso en el 2003 y en el 2011.
Es decir, que con el correr del tiempo
el mundo se va haciendo más igualitario.
Ahora nos enfrentamos a la situación
de afirmar con todas las letras
que la justicia social es injusta.
¿Por qué?
Primero entendamos la lógica populista
que parte, básicamente, de lo que es
la forma de la distribución del ingreso.
Si debajo del ingreso promedio
vive el 75 % de la población,
hay un negocio electoral buenísimo
que es hablar de "pobres y ricos
y que le vamos a sacar a los ricos
para darle a los pobres".
Cuando pasa eso, ¿el resultado cuál es?
Electoralmente garpa un montón,
porque Uds. le están hablando
al 75 % de la población.
Pero lo que hay que entender
es que la torta no es algo que está fijo,
sino que, por la teoría
de la distribución,
Uds. ya vieron que eso es un proceso
dinámico que se genera en el mercado.
Porque si Uds. produjeran algo que
no le sirve a nadie, van a la quiebra
y no sacan ningún ingreso.
Consecuentemente, Uds. ahí lo que tienen
es que la lógica del populismo
y el socialismo lo que hace
es destrozar los incentivos, hace
que la torta termine siendo más chica
y que todos terminemos siendo más pobres.
De hecho, siempre fue un sistema basado
en generar gran cantidad de miseria.
¿Qué decía Milton Friedman de estas cosas?
Decía que aquella sociedad que priorice
la igualdad por encima de la libertad
no va a conseguir nada de ambas.
En cambio, aquella sociedad que priorice
la libertad por sobre la igualdad
va a conseguir mucho de las dos cosas.
Es más, ya lo decía John Stuart Mill,
aquella sociedad que se preocupa más
por la igualdad que por la libertad
termina siendo una sociedad
de saqueadores.
Entonces, acá aparecen
dos grandes logros del liberalismo
que tienen que ver
con la igualdad ante la ley.
Veamos el caso de lo que se llama
la redistribución del ingreso
y el caso de los impuestos progresivos.
Cuando Uds. ponen impuestos progresivos,
es decir, aquellos que
gravan con mayor fuerza
a los que mejor sirven al prójimo con
bienes de mejor calidad a un mejor precio,
eso lo que implica es tratar de manera
desigual frente a la ley a la gente,
castigando al exitoso,
con lo cual castigan a la producción.
Y, además, --les aviso--
este mecanismo es un robo.
Porque es, ni más ni menos,
que hacer caridad a punta de pistola.
Entonces, cuando Uds. caen en esto,
sin lugar a dudas les va a ir mal.
En el fondo lo que Uds.
tienen que comprender
es que estamos frente
a una discusión de valores.
Por un lado, el socialismo basado
en la envidia, el odio, el resentimiento,
la desigualdad ante la ley,
el robo y, por sobre todas las cosas,
tratar de igualar
a los que somos desiguales;
consecuentemente un sistema violento
que siempre se aplicó por la fuerza
y se llevó puesto más de
100 millones de vidas humanas.
Y, por el otro lado, tenemos
el liberalismo, el capitalismo,
ni más ni menos que el respeto irrestricto
al proyecto de vida del prójimo,
basado en la propiedad privada,
basado en los mercados libres,
basado en la poca intervención del Estado,
basado en la división del trabajo,
basado en la cooperación social,
donde se premia el ahorro,
donde se aprecia el esfuerzo del trabajo.
Y todo esto sirviendo al prójimo con
bienes de mejor calidad a un mejor precio.
Es decir, el exitoso en el capitalismo
no es ni más ni menos
que un benefactor social.
Pero, como si todo esto fuera poco,
somos superiores estéticamente.
¡Miren lo que es New York,
miren lo que es Cuba!
Yo no conozco gente yéndose
de New York para Cuba.
Todos quieren ir al "maldito capitalismo".
Es más, estéticamente
hemos sido superiores siempre.
¿Cómo eran los edificios
de la Unión Soviética?
Eran grises, oscuros,
sin ventanas, no les daba la luz.
En cambio, ¿del otro lado qué teníamos?
Teníamos al Guggenheim,
las Torres Gemelas, el edificio Chrysler,
el Empire State.
Digamos, un conjunto de bellezas.
Inventamos la bikini
y la mini falda también.
Miren lo que era el auto
de los rusos, el Lada.
Nosotros tenemos la Ferrari,
el Lamborghini, el Maserati.
En el fondo, estamos en una situación
donde no solo somos
superiores en lo productivo,
no solo hemos sacado millones
de personas de la pobreza,
no solo es el único sistema que es justo,
sino que además somos
estéticamente superiores.
Muchas gracias y
¡viva la libertad, carajo!
(Aplausos)